في كل ايام غزه صعبه لكن نريد ان نعرف ما
الذي جرى في الساعات
الماضيه نعم زين العابدين بالفعل الاوضاع
تزداد
صعوبه يوما بعد يوم وساعه بعد ساعه هنا في
قطع غزه مع دخول الحرب يومها
السادسس قبل قليل وبعد ساعتين من الهدوء
الحذر تحديدا في المنطقه الوسطى والمنطقه
الجن بيه من قطاع غزه تجددت الغارات
الجويه الاسرائيليه واستهدفت عددا من
المنازل الماهوله بالسكان هنا في منطقه
قيزان النجار في قرب منطقه معن جنوب شرقي
خانيونس شنت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
غاره جويه واستهدفت منزلا ماهو بالسكان
بعدد من الصواريخ اصفرت هذه الغاره عن
استشهاد سته فلسطينيين واصابه العشرات
بجروح متفاوته نقلوا جميعا الى مستشفى غزه
الاوروبي لتلقي العلاج بعدها بدقائق شنت
غاره اخرى على مخيم النصيرات واستهدفت
منزلا لعائله ابو عطيوي اصفرت هذه الغاره
عن استشهاد سبعه فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين
بجروح نقلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
وايضا غاره اخرى قرب جسر وادي غزه استهدفت
منزلا اسفرت عن سقوط شهداء وجرحى هذه
الغارات وتجدد واستهداف المنازل مجددا في
المنطقه الوسطى والجنوبيه تتزامن ايضا مع
قصف مدفع اسرائيل استهدف عددا من المناطق
في شرقي مدينه خانيونس وايضا اشتباكات
مسلحه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال في المحورين الشرقي والشمالي من
المدينه حيث اعلنت كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس عن تدمير ثلاث دبابات
اسرائيليه في المحور الشرقي بالاضافه الى
استه استهداف مجموعه من جنود جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في المحور الشمالي بالقذائف
المضاده ل
الافراد الوضع الانساني هنا في قطاع غزه
صعب جدا ولغايه وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الانرو قالت ان مستوى الجوع في القطاع
مثير للقلق وغير مسبوق وان استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي يحول دون وصول هذه المساعدات
الى المحتاجين نتحدث عن اكثر من مليون
ونصف نازح في المنطقه الجنوبيه وايضا
بالتزامن نتحدث عن اكثر من 20,000 شهيد
بينهم
14000 امراه وطفل بالاضافه الى اكثر من
52000 جريح 5000 جريح بحاجه ماسه للسفر
للعلاج عبر معبر رفح البري ايضا الاوضاع
في المنطقه في مدينه غزه والشمال لا تقل
يعني نحن نتحدث عن 52000 جريح و5000 حاله
تحتاج الى نقل الى خارج قطاع غزه للعلاج
كم عدد الذين ينتقلون خارج غزه للعلاج ا
من هذا العدد
الكبير نعم زين العابدين بحسب احصاءات
وزاره الصحه هنا في غزه فان نحو 400 جريح
فقط هم من تمكنوا منذ بدايه الحرب وحتى
هذه اللحظه من السفر عبر معبر رفح للعلاج
في الخارج وهذا الرقم لا يعد اقل من 1% من
اجمالي عدد الجرحى المصابين في قطاع غزه
في ظل الامكانيات الطبيه المعدومه تماما
لدى المستشفيات وعدم وصول المساعدات
الطبيه وايضا الادويه اللازمه الى
المستشفيات بالاضافه الى المعدات اللازمه
لاجراء عمليات جراحيه هؤلاء الجرحى ال
5000 هم مصابون بجروح خطيره وبحاجه لاجراء
عمليات جراحيه معقده لا تتوفر الامكانيات
في مستشفيات القطاع لاجرائها هنا في غزه
مما يضطرهم للسفر للعلاج بالخارج الاعداد
التي يسمح لها بالخروج من غزه عبر معبر
رفح هي اعداد محدوده جدا مقارنه بالارقام
الهائله والكبيره نتحدث عن مئات المصابين
الذين يصلون يوميا الى المستشفيات المراكز
الصحيه في القطاع وهي تفوق القدره
الاستيعابيه لهذه المستشفيات وايضا قدره
الكوادر الطبيه وامكانياتها ونتحدث عن
مدينه غزه والشمال حيث خرجت جميع
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه في المنطقه
الشماليه من غزه عن الخدمه تماما نتيجه
الاستهداف والقصف الاسرائيلي المباشر
والحصار المفروض كما هو المثال في مستشفى
العوده الذي يخضع لحصار اسرائيلي مشدد منذ
ايام ويمنع دخول الماء والدواء وحتى
الغذاء للمرضى والكوادر الطبيه علاوه على
استهدافهم بالقنص ما ادى الى سقوط عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى في صفوفهم من مستشفى ناصر
في خانيونس مراسل الجزيره مؤمن شرافي شكرا
لك